[Music]
love is
raining down on ariana grande i'm happy
life is good yeah whoever said love
can't survive quarantine hasn't heard of
ari and her new man
dalton gomez a source tells et the two
who are self-isolating together in los
angeles amid the coronavirus pandemic
are in a
really good place and quarantine has
been
a great opportunity for them to spend
quality time together
it's the most fun i've ever had in my
whole life rumors that ari was dating
the luxury real estate agent
started swirling back in march and she
straight up confirmed it in the music
video for her collab with justin bieber
stuck with you
yeah nothing says it's official like a
music video cameo
am i right
but et source says the pop star has had
some hesitation being so public about
her relationship with dalton
as she's seen how that has worn on her
past relationships
it was like so crazy yeah like her
very public engagement to pete davidson
you know what like like if we break up
and we won't we will but we won't
anyway the whole taking their romance
public thing
hasn't seemed to hurt arya dalton's love
no matter what i'm grateful
in fact he even helped her promote her
new collab with lady gaga
rain on me this week holding the shower
head to make it rain on ari in this skit
to promote the track
oh we are thirsty indeed and what the
locals are now saying globally is
rain on me ari also shared this behind
the scenes clip of dalton
literally making it rain on twitter and
avi
the internet loved it all of it one fan
wrote
never seen a man so happy to create fake
rain with a hose for anyone
keep him while another wrote on
instagram
dalton in the background i'm crying
it'll be raining all summer but we'll
surely be dancing as it does